hello everyone thank you for joining us
for today's webinar
understanding batten disease
pathogenesis presented by dr. Jonathan
Cooper professor pediatrics
Washington University School of Medicine
st. Louis my name is Xavier Gutierrez
and I will be your moderator for today's
event
Riya delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation and if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing the problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Cooper I will
now turn the presentation over to him so
hello everybody it's a pleasure to be
with you today
and to have the opportunity to tell you
some of the work that we've been doing
to understand a group of diseases called
batten disease and the main reason we're
doing all of this work is because we're
trying to come up for therapies for
these fatal inherited disorders so first
I'd like to introduce the diseases to
you
they have a long scientific name which
is neuronal Sirois deliver fuschia
gnosis but typically we refer to them as
batten disease which is actually an
umbrella term for a whole family of
related diseases they're named after the
gentleman you can see there in the top
corner of the screen frederick Batam it
was an eminent British pediatrician who
described these early in the 20th
century now they are a whole group of
diseases that have been put together
initially we thought there were only
four of them now it's recognized that
there are
14 and maybe more of these diseases that
have been grouped together on the basis
that they are all profoundly
neurodegenerative all the one also
involve degeneration of the retina but
they have very characteristically this
buildup of auto fluorescent storage
material inside the lysosome and that
feature of material building up inside
the lines of some is what makes them
what we call a lysosomal storage
disorder because things aren't building
out within the lysosome that shouldn't
be there and I'll explain in a moment
why that happens
clinically these are diseases that start
at very different ages they can start
from just after birth all the way
through to an adult onset form but they
share certain common features being that
affected individuals will suffer visual
failure progressively worse seizures and
a horrible and relentless decline in
both cognitive function and motor
ability and sadly all of these are
faithful diseases and that's why we're
working very hard to both understand
them and come up with Erebus for them
now they are grouped together largely on
the basis of that storage material that
builds up and it's very easy to see we
can simply shine ultraviolet light upon
sanctions that we don't even have to
stain them and you can see here the
lysosomes that are chock-full of that
material that should have been degraded
that is bill built up inside them now
these are all inherited diseases they
each of them is caused by mistake in a
different gene that what we would call
monogenic in that it is a single gene
defect in each form and depending on
which gene carries that mutation
determines which age and how fast the
disease progresses now with only one
exception they're all inherited in a
classic autosomal recessive fashion
meaning that both parents are carriers
they are heterozygous for these
mutations and every time they have a
child there is a one in four chance that
that child will inherit the mutation
from each of the parents and having two
copies of the mutated gene means the
child will unfortunately have the
disease now as I said they fall into the
category of diseases that are called
lysosomal storage disorders and I just
like to take a short moment
to explain what those are so if we look
at the cartoon cell containing lots of
different organelles our main centre of
interest is the lysosome and we can
think of the lysosome very simply as
being the cell's waste disposal center
it contains machinery you can think of
Italy the scissors I prefer to use the
pinecone analogy that are going to break
down proteins that are no longer wanted
inside the cell so that they can perhaps
more accurately rather than simply waste
disposal be recycled so that they can
then be used to make further proteins
now what happens in each of all of these
diseases is that that process of waste
disposal breaks down there is a failure
in the recycling and we get to buildup
of material or stuff inside the lines of
Soma that's the auto fluorescent
material that I showed you on the
previous slide how that actually happens
if we look at a cartoon version of the
lysosome itself a double-walled vesicle
inside the cell inside it there are
multiple enzymes pac-man as I've used
here their job is to degrade material
that ends up in the lysosome and get rid
of it now what happens in all of these
diseases and all of the lines are so
more disorders is that those enzymes
become dysfunctional and what happens
it's rather like if a waste disposal
units at home were to go wrong if that
fails stuff would simply build up inside
that lysosome or inside your waste
disposal unit so you end up with one
that's full that is precisely what we
consider when we look down a microscope
it's also what you can see in our lab
that I know when we work on a group of
these diseases all of which affect
children so we have called the pediatric
storage disorders laboratory now there
happen to be about 70 different diseases
like this and while they might each
individually be very rare and we're
talking like one in two hundred thousand
maybe put them together all of those
that is some more like one in five
thousands of children will have one of
these diseases and given that they are
fatal we actually really want to do
something about that and come up with
therapies for preventing these children
from dying
so what actually happens in the
different forms of NCL to use the
abbreviation that we typically use is
that we have genes that are mutated that
are actually in different places inside
the cell so many of them are an enzyme
or that Bank map and that's true for the
infantile the late infantile the ceilin
tenkan gentle form and probably for the
CLN five form is that we have a mutation
in a gene that should code for an enzyme
because of that mutation we get no
enzyme made there are also forms of NCL
which are a mutation in a quite
different sort of protein so that wiggly
line is how scientists like to show a
transmembrane protein that was sitting
in the wall of the lysosome and that's
true for the juvenile seal and three
form of the disease and also for seal at
seven however there are other forms of
NZ again that are mutations in
transmembrane proteins that are coded
elsewhere inside the cell so either in
the Golgi apparatus or in the
endoplasmic reticulum as is true for
seal and 6 and C Ln 8 and by mechanisms
which are only really just becoming
apparent this has a knock-on effect upon
the lysosome so the story is that
effectively we have different protein
deficiencies that take places in
different places inside the cell in each
of the forms of the disease so we're
beginning to see that they're not
actually that similar to one another as
you might think so I'd like to emphasize
that point that we do have quite
different forms about and disease or NCL
so some of them fall into that enzyme
deficiency category typically c ln 1 + c
ln 2 others fit into that transmembrane
protein division form prototype k c ln 3
disease now given that we have diseases
that are caused by mutations in genes
that have very different functions and
are in different types of proteins even
in different places inside the cell it
wouldn't necessarily be a surprise that
how things go wrong which is another way
of explaining the word pathogenesis
would be rather different between these
different forms of the disease equally
when it comes to devise
therapy's the implications are quite
different for those enzyme deficient
forms we can rely on the mechanism of
cross correction in that there are
receptors sitting on the surface of
cells waiting to catch any enzyme that
we could deliver to a brain so that will
be taken up to cross correct the
neighboring deficient cells that isn't a
possibility for a transmembrane division
form of NCR and we're largely looking at
trying to understand all of the
downstream effects of those mutations
and come up with other ways to try and
block those effects and hope that they
will be therapeutic although as we're
discovering now gene therapy is holding
a lot of potential for those
transmembrane forms the disease - so the
foundation on which all our work is done
is working in a series of different
animal models and our challenge is to
know and to understand those different
models be their knockout mouse or be
they are naturally occurring larger
animal species like you know a dog or a
sheep is to try and understand them now
they are all good for particular
purposes but they equally have their
limitations and we have to remember they
are purely a model for the human disease
but what we like to do is to ask some
very simple or as I would call them
chicken and the egg questions about
these models and use that to answer our
understanding of the disease and for
[ __ ] for words so what are the
landmarks one of the things that we
actually wish to measure measure in
those is it pathology is it tissue
culture is it biochemistry is it
behavior that will be most informative
and effectively what we're doing is
defining how these diseases start and
how they progress now the reason for
doing that while it's interesting from a
scientific perspective is actually with
a very focused purpose which is to
define where and when and how we can
deliver our therapies to be most
effective so the way that we do that in
my laboratory is understanding largely
pathology and that can be pathology and
mice or it can be in those sheep or pigs
or dogs as we shall see later so our
starting point is the brain and here is
the brain of a mouse and we prepare a
series of different sections and stained
them in a variety
of different ways to learn things and
find particular indicators of pathology
often boom before we prepare those
sanctions we have done behaviour on most
mice or we may have taken cells from
other mice and growing them in tissue
culture to ask particular questions or
we may have looked at gene and protein
expression but if we turn our attention
most exposed tissue sanctions we wanting
to extract numbers we use a series of
different microscope techniques and
series of different packages to extract
numbers about how the structure in those
brains has actually changed that can
involve doing things like threshold in
you machine analysis to ask how much of
something is there for example we might
measure how much of that storage
material is present or how many of the
indicators of disease might have
disappeared but a lot of it also comes
down to doing stereo logical unbiased
geological measures of structures in the
brain and sterility as we'll see is a
very important method particularly in
brains that have changed their shape as
a result of disease and all of that work
we do is blind to treatment and to
genotype so that the people who were
doing these studies don't actually know
which animal is which and it's only at
the end of our studies that we crack the
code and sort the danger into different
groups in trying to determine whether
our treatment may have had an effect or
not so just so emphasize why sterility
is important obviously the main focus of
our disease that we're interested in is
the brain and the brain contains
millions of billions of neurons and
Counting every one of those is not
feasible even within just one small part
of the brain we become bored doing that
counsel would become inaccurate so what
we do effectively it's to sample a known
fraction of that tissue and based on
that estimate of what we counted in a
small bit we then extrapolate up to what
was in all the bits we didn't waste our
time counting now for that method to
actually work it's crucial that the
sample that we take must be completely
unbiased and that's a term for sampling
structures within the brain and it's as
cells get bigger or the brain might
shrink our probability of sampling them
would change so we have to come
with a method that will overcome that
that method is done by superimposing a
grid that's regularly spaced on top of
sections that are themselves regularly
spaced of known thickness and then we
ask simple yes-or-no questions in a
small box called a detector frame and
from that we can get rapid and efficient
ways to obtain unbiased data from brains
that may have atrophy significantly or
in which the cells may have either
shrunken or got bigger because they're
filling with storage material and that's
why story ology is a very important
method to use so the sorts of things
that we're looking at obviously these
are profoundly nourishing density
generative diseases so we have a lot of
neurons that are dying we have that
buildup of storage material we also have
a lot of inflammation within the brain
in terms of reaction of astrocytes
process called astro-psychosis
something similar of microglia within
the brain and we also have synaptic
pathology that we know takes place now
many of these have things happen in a
whole range of other diseases to the
house with the exception of the storage
accumulation but are interested in
actually looking at what is the
relationship between these events and
how is their timing different in
different brain regions and all of that
is in terms of being able to target our
therapies now as a result of many years
work we know that these diseases
effectively end up at a very similar
endpoint but they may take a different
path to reach that pathological end
stage and that's exactly what we've been
trying to get to the bottom of the first
thing that we discovered is that not all
neurons respond the same way in these
particular diseases so some neuron
populations are more vulnerable and
counter-arguments some are actually more
resistant to the effects of disease we
first discovered that for populations of
GABAergic inter neurons which help
control brain activity and it's not a
surprise that they might be defective in
a disorder where we see seizures perhaps
more surprisingly was that the relay or
in
information from the thalamus up to the
cortex was affected farther from earlier
than the cortex itself the dogma was
that this was a cortical disease it may
end up being so but largely secondary to
efface within the thalamus there is also
a theme that the larger and more
complicated neurons are the more likely
they are to be vulnerable and examples
are lamina 5 pyramidal cells or Purkinje
cells within the cerebellum and recently
we found another good example which is
the selective pathology that we see
early in the disease within the spinal
cord now obviously if different things
are happening in different places this
has big implications for where and when
we should be delivering our therapy to
have the greatest effect now an obvious
question is what's actually causing this
selective neuron loss and the first
finger of suspicion pointed at that
storage material perhaps largely because
it is so easy to find simply by shiny
ultraviolet lights upon us action but
when we measured where and when that
material was building up it did not have
any direct relationship to which neuron
populations were dying suggesting that
the two events are not actually linked
on what we think is that as the disease
progresses towards a lot of neurons
dying that this storage material is
effectively a non crucial byproduct as
part of the disease it's a disease
marker but it's not the most important
event and that raises the question then
what else might be important if it's not
the storage material now it turns out
that one of the best and earliest
predictors of neuron loss is something
that I've already mentioned which is
that Galen from glial activation or
inflammation that takes place within the
brain the surprise was that this was
happening in very small patches of the
brain very early in the disease was
actually happening before neurons were
dying and it turns out that this is
actually a very accurate predictor of
where subsequently most neurons will go
on to die and those that die first and
it turns out to be a much better
predictor than their build up of the
storage material
one of the first place would be to find
that property was actually in a sheep
model of the disease and discovered it
was present actually very early in the
disease in those sheep it's actually
present prenatally and that of course
raises the question whether this is as
present in many other similar diseases
now it raises the question as to whether
this is a positive or negative event in
disease progression if it's something
that's a positive potentially
regenerative thing is something we might
encourage if it's a negative event is
something that we might wish to try and
control or downtown so we've been
looking at that and asking recently
what's the contribution of these clear
and that inflammatory process to the
disease progression in multiple forms of
the disease this comes around because
any in a regular healthy brain there is
a intimate relationship between the
neurons the astrocytes and the microglia
that is crucial for normal brain
function and whilst most of our
attention has been on the neurons as the
culprits in this particular disease is
entirely plausible about problems within
the astrocytes or the microglia could
end up with causing a cascade of error
increasing problems that end up with
neurons dying now it's entirely
plausible that astrocytes and microglia
could be affected because they to
express those genes which are defective
in these diseases so we've been asking
very simply how is each of these
different cell types affected in the
disease and how are the interactions
between these cells altered and we've
been doing this comparing across for
three major forms of the disease cm + 1
7 2 + CL m3 disease now the way that we
do this is by going cultures from early
postnatal mouse brains and we have
methods where we can grow cultures of
just those astrocytes or just microglia
or just neurons and then ask very simply
how is it yourself i perfected in each
of the different form of NCL once we've
then defined that we can then start
mixing and matching and in co-culture
systems we can grow different
combinations of astrocytes and baikin
and neurons and makes them match healthy
or mutant cells and see how they
interact and influence one another so
what I'm going to do is talk through
some of the results we've gone from
first CN n 3 and then seal N 1 mice and
show you what we actually found so this
work started and I mean talk first about
CN n 3 was that looking at the brains of
these mice we found that whilst
astrocytes were becoming activated to
the point they were up regulating the
expression of the marker called GF ap
they weren't actually changing their
shape normally so at the top there we
can see a wild-type healthy Mouse which
you see a pale East Ames astrocyte that
looks a bit like a firework burst going
off in the far right there you can see
cells that have become fully activated
they have a much larger cell body they
stain much darker and have very few but
think processes in the middle we see a
CL n 3 mouse in which yes it is darker
and more Brown but it hasn't changed its
shape fully it's as if it's got started
and then got stuck part way along
through that process now that's
something that we also see in our
cultures from those mice and that when
we stimulate the cells they can't change
their shape as readily as a healthy
cells would and that's because they have
a series of scientists illegal defects
and that has a knock-on effect on their
ability to migrate into a scratch I say
done in again in tissue culture not
surprisingly because they have spicy
skeletal problems we also see that they
have a series of defects in their
abilities to secrete chemokines and
cytokines and that is more pronounced in
astrocytes than is seen in microglia
which have no problems in fact cytosin
thing as we give them those astrocytes
are certainly very severely affected
they have trouble taking up glutamate
within a culture which would obviously
have implications for exciting toxicity
they also have problem in generating
spontaneous calcium waves which is how
astrocytes talk to one another
suggesting that this process may also be
impaired in cm3 disease
we also learnt the neurons if we grow
neurons from cm3 disease mice we see
that they must they don't die they do
have very particular structural defects
in their dendrites which may well be
related to their ability to communicate
with one another and an interesting
phenotype that their axon initial
segment the interesting part of this
particularly came when we started
growing neurons and glia together so
this is growing a mixed culture of the
neurons and the astrocytes and the
writing we're together and what we found
was that ceylon three mutant cells those
mutant clear can actually kill neurons
they will harm healthy neurons but they
actually killed mutant CLM three neurons
but if we then grew healthy glia
together with sick neurons this was
actually capable of protecting the
phenotype for those sick neurons
suggesting that if we could actually
treat clear we may be able to help
rescue some of those neurons so armed
with that information we then conducted
very similar experiments and see how
that one disease perhaps foolishly
thinking we might find something very
similar but in actual fact we found
quite a different story what we found
was that microglia and clm one disease
or actually far more activated even
before we stimulated them but when we
did they responded perfectly normally
which is quite unlike CLN three what we
did find though was that seen on one
might really appear to have an impaired
ability to eat up small latex beads so
impaired phagocytosis turning our
attention to Astro science they to see
when one astrocytes were more activated
basically before we even stimulated them
but again they had a normal scientist
concerned and responded normally to
stimulation again two things that Ceylon
three astrocytes had problems in doing
we also find that they had differences
in their ability to secrete chemokines
and cytokines but quite different to
those we saw in Ceylon three disease we
then looked in more detail at the
astrocytes and found surprisingly but
over time
there are many fewer sailor and one
astrocytes in our culture's suggesting
that they were simply dying in a ditch
they appears to die by a process of
apoptosis and that parallels some data
that we have from the brains of these
mites in vivo we also found that there
were particular calcium signaling
abnormalities in those CL and one
astrocytes and that they had higher
levels of cytoplasmic calcium and this
was being released from lysosomal rather
than er stores we then looked at the
neurons the CM n1 deficient neurons and
we found that unlike CN n 3 they too
were vulnerable in a dish so few and
urine survived a bit like this m1
astrocytes were doing dying over time so
with the CL n1 neurons but this was most
pronounced for the inhibitory neurons
just as it is in vivo again this appears
to be in via process of apoptosis
but the surviving neurons looking sicker
and having a smaller cell body they also
have a range of dendritic abnormalities
- but they're different to those we saw
in CL n3 neurons and there are a series
of synaptic defects - we then started
doing those Cod cultures and this is
where the story became particularly
interesting firstly if we grew ceiling
when astrocytes and microglia together
while both cell types were inherently
more activated when they were grown
together they became more activated
still as if they are crosstalking or
priming one another if rougarou's clm
one astrocytes and neurons together we
found that the astrocytes would impair
how those neurons appeared but didn't
actually kill them whereas if we grew CL
m1 microglia and neurons together those
microglia were capable of killing a
subset of the neurons and the remainder
looked sick
however when we grew everything together
astrocytes markedly and neurons together
we found that that process of cell death
was far more pronounced it appears that
the astrocytes come wandering they are
combining to exacerbate the effects on
neuron survival so
put together we actually have whole new
perspective on the disease one of the
important things I'd like to gear and
leave you with the message of is that
these diseases are not the same as one
another in both CLM 1 and Sealand 3
disease we have dysfunctional glare but
they are dysfunction in quite different
ways so there are actually really
different diseases at a cellular level
another very important thing to come out
of these studies is that while we have
been previously thinking purely of
treating the neurons we really should be
thinking of also treating the clear when
we are devising therapies of these are
cells that clearly are dysfunctional and
appear to be contributing in a big way
to the disease process and so we are now
attempting to block these sorts of
effects with a range of different
compounds so moving on to another
section one's give you another example
of how pathology is very useful in terms
of informing the therapeutic efforts
that we are trying to do so I said
earlier we've been asking which parts of
the brain are affected well that's
really important because we need to put
the therapy in the right place and we're
actually finding a whole series of new
and perhaps surprising targets both
within the nervous system and also
within the rest of the body and a good
example of that that I mentioned earlier
risk that really was a great surprise to
find that there was pathology within the
spinal cord very early in the disease in
Seema and one disease mice we know that
happens not just him nice but we know
there is also spinal pathology in humans
he men one disease and we know from our
studies that this appears to contribute
to the disease outcome it also is to be
present in many of the other forms of
NCL too so we think that this is an
important problem to tackle and we've
been trying to don't go about doing this
by doing gene therapy to provide a
functional copy of the genes deliver the
enzyme that is missing and I'm going to
go through a series of data that will
show you how and why we did those
studies and how we came up with these
effects
so we were treating our CMN 1 - between
therapy into their brains and we found
that we were able to largely rescue
pathology wherever we got that therapy
so effectively the four brains of these
mice had been cured
however those mice were still dying
telling us that treating the brain
itself wasn't sufficient to have a full
cure of the disease so that suggested
that we had actually missed something
and that there might be some important
pathology elsewhere that we needed to
target - and it turned out that where we
had missed was actually that there was a
massive amount of unexpected pathology
within the spinal cord we first saw that
that was present within the human
disease and then went looking within the
mice and sure enough it was there - and
it was there in the spinal cord before
pathology started within the brain so we
then started trying to treat that and so
in addition to directing gene therapy
into the brain so intracranial we also
directed our gene therapy into the
spinal cord intrathecally by means of
something like a lumbar puncture and so
whether we look at the amount of storage
material that's present or whether we
look at micro glial activation
effectively where we post that therapy
we've managed to cure the disease so we
have an untreated Mouse at the bottom we
have a wild-type Mouse that has very
little inflammation we have an untreated
mutant Mouse that has inflammation in
both the brain and the spinal cord if we
treat the spinal cord alone so in
intrathecal treatment we effectively fix
the spinal cord but don't touch the
brain the disease is still present there
if we direct our therapy to the brain
alone we are able to treat that
pathology there but don't touch the cord
however if we treat both sides we can
effectively prevent that pathology from
taking place in both sites per house
most importantly is that this didn't
simply have an additive effect but was
synergistic this is looking at
behavioral data and we can see that the
ability of the mice to stay on our
spinning rod
rosarot is much much better when we
treat both sites but perhaps most
importantly was that the lifespan of
those mice was effectively tripled if we
look at the blue line in the lifespan
curve there an untreated mutant will die
around eight months of age if we treat
just the spinal cord that will go out
about 12 months we treat the brain alone
that will go out to about 16 months but
if we actually treat both the brain and
the spinal cord were able to get those
mice now to live now these three times
as long as they would have done had to
be not treated them so it is by far the
best therapeutic efficacy that we have
seen so far in this particular disease
and all of that approach came about
purely because we had discovered there
was pathology in an unexpected site and
we are now looking out ways to try and
improve this further by targeting the
places where we think there is
additional pathology taking place within
the rest of the body of these mice so
I've talked a lot about mice and mice
have been very useful and very important
for our experiments but it's important
to remember that a mouse brain is not
really much like human brain it's rather
small and is rather simple and we need
to find ways to scale up our delivery to
a much larger and much more complicated
brain than I've already mentioned the
use of some larger animal species is
were mostly naturally occurring but now
there is the possibility to generate
such moles by CRISPR accounts time these
larger models give pathology that's much
more like the human disease and are a
very effective testing ground for the
practical issues of how to deliver
therapies so there exist naturally
occurring and and genetically engineered
sheep there also exist genetically
engineered pigs and I'm going to give
you an example of some of this work that
we did in a naturally occurring model of
semen to disease that led to the first
fda-approved therapy for any of these
particular diseases this work was all
done in collaboration with a company
called bio marine and they were working
with ATP p1
patient ID accent so a naturally
occurring model has a mutation that
gives it a disease which is effectively
CL and to disease in a dot so they were
delivering human recombinant enzyme into
that ventricles the fluid filled spaces
in the brains of those dogs and we at
the end of that study have a look at the
pathology and looking at the storage
look in the information within the
brains and what we found was there was a
remarkably positive effect upon
pathology in those treated dogs and that
was true even at the end stage of the
disease those effects weren't confined
to pathology but it effectively improved
disease in these dogs they had a much
longer life span a much better quality
of life and improved cognitive and
neurological performance so those that
work which we were involved in was the
testing ground that led to a successful
clinical trial for this approach in
people where the same enzyme was being
delivered through a port into the
ventricles and this subsequently at the
end of phase 1 to clinical trial it was
shown that this was effective in
stabilizing the disease at the stage
that it was given and that led to the
FDA approval of Brian Yura as a product
which is now proved for the treatment to
seal into disease in children and just
to emphasize all of that came from
following the same pathway that we have
talked about in this lecture
understanding pathology understanding
where it is and being able to target it
to the right place at the right time to
have a treatment effect now it's great
that we have got to that point for c92
disease but we need to make effectively
the same progress for all of these
different diseases for all the forms of
batten disease so the children who
suffer from the other forms will have
the same hope of the treatment in the
future so our challenge is actually to
turn experiments that we do in our
animal models ultimately into clinical
trials and for those to become
treatments so in finishing this lecture
I've shared with you some of the basic
principles of these diseases I hope you
have seen that these diseases are not
simply the same do
is happening at different ages but they
have quite different underlying ways in
which the cells in these brains are
actually affected it is also true from a
clinical perspective towards a clinician
so you see these children they are not
quite the same disease but there are
particular differences it's important to
understand that not all parts of the
brain or indeed as we're learning the
body or even cells within those
different parts of the brain are
affected in the same way or to the same
extent it's also important to understand
that whilst we have animal models the
pathology can be quite different between
those species so really understanding
them is very important and understanding
that gives us the vital information of
where to put the therapy and when to
deliver it so that can be most effective
and as we're learning some of those
places began to deliver it may well be
in the future outside the brain so that
we can have a complete treatment effect
so thank you for listening I'll be happy
to take questions that you can send it
via email I have to close by
acknowledging the work that everyone has
done this is very much a team effort I'm
very fortunate to have a group of very
talented people in my lab at Washu but
we have worked together with many people
in many places all around the world to
make this happen
we've been fortunate to be funded by a
whole series of organizations and work
together with some companies to move
this work forward thank you for
listening
thank you dr. Cooper for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go
I want to let everyone know that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through June of 2019 and as a
final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any of your questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again sir